hitman 3 is a timed epic game store
exclusive
yes we're getting a brand new call of
duty and there are some more details
about the playstation 5
dual sense controller i'm lucy and these
are your biggest gaming news stories
for thursday august 20th
[Music]
hello 47 hitman 3 will be a timed
exclusive on the epic game store
when it launches in january next year as
part of the deal you can grab hitman
2016 for free between
august 27th and september 3rd if you
grabbed the previous hitman games on
steam
then have no fear your progress will
carry over to the epic game store
developer io interactive has also
revealed a brand new location for hitman
3
thornbridge manor in dartmoor england
more intriguingly they're describing
this level as a mix of a classic
whodunit
and reverse murder mystery more like
downton
stabby am i right i cannot take credit
for that that was will on our social
team
shout outs to will all right enough
mucking about we've got a new call of
duty coming
i'm english and i can't even do a london
accent a brand new teaser video confirms
it the next call of duty is called black
ops
cold war now the video is mostly footage
of a speech from real life kgb defector
yuri besmanov
plus other historical footage now the
end of the teaser flashes the cold war
name again
and shows logos for the developers which
this time around are treyarch
and raven software they also revealed
some brand new art for the game
and confirmed that the worldwide full
reveal will be next wednesday august
26th
and it will take place within verdansk
which we all know
as the place that war zone is set be
sure to check back next week where we'll
have all the details on cod blop's cow
i'm gonna make that happen and sony has
revealed some
cool new tidbits about how the dual
sense controller is being used by
developers
who are creating games for the
playstation 5. for example in spider-man
miles morales
you'll have spidey sense and using the
controller's haptic feedback will let
you know which direction an attack is
coming from
yes definitely did get delayed into 2021
but when we do actually play it the cool
thing is
that it'll actually block the triggers
when your gun jams
and demon souls will use haptic feedback
to let you feel
when you've pulled off a perfect parry
and speaking of demon souls
my god i really hope those rumors about
it coming this year
are true tomorrow we'll have another
episode of generation next our brand new
show all about the ps5 and series x
where this week we're discussing what
our dream launch lineups
for both consoles will be so make sure
to check back then also head over to
store.gamespot.com
to grab your play for all and gamespot
merch all proceeds are going to black
lives matter
and direct relief until the end of the
month thanks for watching this episode
of save state i'm on twitter lucy james
games and i'll see you next time
[Music]
you